hey guys welcome back to brand new v2
Rebecca forged serger we should off the
new emote that just came out the
volcanic destruction blast and I'm gonna
be having it with the rep six the effect
actually it's really cool having the red
and yellow come together so I'm
definitely glad I'm gonna be picking
this up as always it is a ten thousands
to vote I believe yes it is ten thousand
steel and it's only available for the
first week and it will go away forever
so if you do want to grab this you
definitely want to be getting it now
before it goes away so with that let's
get in the duels for today and the first
opponent is going to be against and
believe a red six Highlander that's
pretty interesting
I forgot I didn't see his actual overall
rep but you know we got the rep six fish
off the hadouken real quick and match
this a really long email only issue I
have is that it is long but thankfully
this dude is very okay would be shooting
this at him and I like the guy that just
wants to gank me either way let's get
into this fight he's gonna try to get
into offensive as quick as possible
oh damn Go Go move it on the fast side
for that watch for that move you guys
have to forgive me for a bit I've been
out of town for a couple days and I
haven't been able to play for honor
either
so very very rusty at this at the moment
damn bro good parry that's gonna hurt me
hard I just couldn't do a little bit
more light attacks I was huh I was
trying to do something other than just
the side - moves but he kept throwing up
the Celts a curse and it's like the best
counter to it so I was like [ __ ] it oh
just keep doing it for him keep doing it
good fights it best thing you want to be
doing is baiting out the offensive
stance as much as possible damn right
this match needs more zones
oh that's trash super unlucky on that
guard break damn good stuff did random
whip of the unblockable heavy and the
guard break range that was that was just
an unlucky flight that sucks
but I have confidence that I can beat
this guy just a few bit you know just a
few mistakes I've been [ __ ] out
Olga Perry makes her the light I don't
know if that's the most thing he can get
I know his heavies are pretty long so
I'm pretty sure that's all he could get
I'm I'm actually impressed that my guard
didn't go for that first heavy cuz yeah
I'm just weak sauce or whatever the [ __ ]
the reasoning was a good crushing
counter wrote damn he clapped me hard we
can come back it's only one to two
there's a few mistakes like I said I've
been making throughout this fight that I
should hopefully be correcting not doing
as many side dash lights just because of
the fact that because he knows the
timings for those so I'm gonna see if I
can try switch it up get a bit more
faints in there I gotta catch him on the
I gotta catch him on the light attack
but he goes backwards with it which is a
good move which is good for Highlanders
because of course you don't you just
want to get an offensive stance with
that you're not really trying to hit
people with lights as much I mean if you
hit them all power to you what the whole
real reason is just to get into
offensive stance that's why he's backing
up and throwing away compareed we better
be GG that was a good parry I actually
[ __ ] that up in my head
I meant AK I actually don't leave the
role like a heavier son like my mind was
not clicking to parry that but it still
worked out so - - this games going on
pretty long dragging it to Round five
but I think I can I think I could do
this he's been bringing me to pretty low
health I need to parry his heavy air his
light attack that's the issue right now
is that he's doing too many lights and
I'm taking mad damage from it
Wow that hit while I'm impressed he's
got me in the circle now okay
damn Highlanders attacks do so much
damage look they do just a bit too much
you rebated out for that so many times
which is only this is the only issue I
have with that is that you can be hit
you [ __ ] up one one time and you got a
third your health work on thanks bud
quick zone there anyone just to end that
with the game five the quick dash
forward light could fly gesture let's
move on to game that to the next
character we're gonna be fighting is a
rep 5r Musha he's rep but 120 overall
I'm rep 100 so I'm pretty close in terms
of overall rank I have the slightest
feeling I'm going to be light spam to
death in this fight
he's definitely trying for the for the
full blocks a lot that could has done a
lot of damage if an impaired yet the
second heavy and the especially the
top-heavy oh it is so much damage so
he's almost within kill range
oh I just got [ __ ] baited that's
gonna hurt me hard thanks bud to give me
that nice so yeah I [ __ ] up a little
bit I was I thought he was gonna follow
through with the zone I keep forgetting
our mushas never really do that so that
he baited me out for that I almost took
out my health bar but doing that zone
cost him a lot of stamina and then with
the hit of my shield I took all the
stamina with his own attack so a few
things that he messed up on in that
fight maybe got a little cocky or
whatever it was but that was really
close to a parry I was really guessing
that Dan didn't that cobble it's been
like in the beginning of this game I had
to get the first leg before it even
happens
throughout a heavy because I know he's
gonna faint it so just pretend like
you're gonna parry it if he faints it
fainted into a light
he'll try to go for something that be
game to guarantee damage on the zone
your stuff dude it's too long the only
it's the one issue I have this emo is
that it's too long to show off once
you've done or once you've killed them
you have to do it like immediately and
you barely show it that's that's to be
my only gripe with the other I mean
other than that it's a really cool emo
but I just wish it wasn't as long really
was going for that deep like there I was
super close misses on the guard break
that's bad cuz bad I was we expecting
the zone I was I was calling it before
he swung my garden whilst went away in
that move feels bad
Oh perfect
just enough spacing we'll get an
execution on that to end and then now
with the three Oh win
on the second game let's go to Game
three and the last match of the day is
gonna be gets the same dude who had the
arm motion but now on Valkyrie now a lot
of you guys know not really good against
Valkyrie so we'll see how this goes
maybe he can end up you know defeating
me or maybe I can somehow clutch it out
we'll have to see how this match goes
he's been in a far distance I'm gonna
think a dashing top light I was a little
bit off on the parry a bit salty but I
was guessing it usually never someone's
this close they always want to go for
the - moves just cuz it's the best thing
that they got at that range damn bro
that triple light that's gonna hurt
dashing top light maybe she's pretty far
ooh multiple heavy faints I like that
that third light though in that chain
does wall splat which is a real
interesting key move it would take the
trait perfect I [ __ ] up on a lot of
things I didn't expect her to whip out a
triple top light very rare most
Valkyries at least that I've played
don't really do that so I was definitely
not expecting that to come up but we'll
see how that goes
damn a little bit late on that perfect
thing for the deef life boys meant to
throw them into the wall a little bit my
fault
as if he thinks I'm [ __ ] up in this
round but that light is so quick damn
good car break it's good faint
I'm definitely getting it the one thing
I need to do to deftly turn the tide on
this battle is to start pairing those
dashing lights I've blocked multiple of
them I have yet to Perry won this game
so I'm gonna try we're gonna try to
switch that up this time what do you
mean our lights aren't incredibly hard
to block but they are pretty fast
usually Valkyries will try to go top
since the the top light and this the
second top light is 400 milliseconds
that being the fastest move I believe
she has so doing that is like very
critical oh it's gonna be a gg for me
good stuff I was uh it was more spacing
my weapons bugging the [ __ ] out it was
more spacing I did the dashing top light
rant you know it wasn't enough to close
the distance
I accidentally move when she did that so
I got [ __ ] up with that I'm so
impressed by this color scheme on this
weapon too it's all pink I've never seen
a pink Valkyrie before
it's one to two hopefully even clutch it
out
trying to get it have reactive asur move
not just guard break me eight times damn
else close real well that second one oh
that's gonna be that's gonna hurt in GG
minute sure you're not staying at the
perfect time too but good fight men got
really unlucky with that Valkyries
pretty crazy in this rear but yeah guys
it's going to be the end of it if we
guys did enjoy it got a little bit
unlucky on the Valkyrie they're
surprised it killed our Musa with the
whole life spam there's a few mistakes
and I messed up on the Valkyrie probably
should have been pairing a lot more for
light attacks I was close on a few of
them well I could never actually
successfully parry one so I'll have to
figure that out for the next battle hey
guys hope you guys did enjoy let me know
your thoughts about this uh this new
emote I actually kind of like this emo I
don't think it might be worth 10k to you
I think it's an only worth 10k I
personally think it's worth it only
because it's available for a week like I
said I just wish it's just a little bit
on a shorter in terms of the duration of
it yeah on TV if you do enjoy mr.
discography new I cover the
informational side of fauna that being
balance changes hero updates patch notes
all that good stuff as well as putting
out some gladiator gameplay and some
future James you and gameplay because
that's going to be my new main for
marching fire and with that guys hope
you agree yesterday I think of arson
[Music]